en parallèle à la campagne de
vaccination qui s'est amorcée en
décembre
les tests de dépistage eux se
multiplient cette fois avec le
déploiement des tests rapides le
coronavirus est un assaillant tenace le
repousse et au combat permanent
et dans l'arsenal des moyens pour briser
sa course
les tests rapides se déploie enfin dans
les aéroports les centres de dépistage
et d'hébergement et même dans les lieux
de travail les tests rapides pour
dépister la coved 19 se répand mais
quand où et auprès de qui sont ils les
plus utiles
[Musique]
depuis la fin mars le nombre de tests
quotidiens réalisés au québec a été
multiplié par 7 environ mais c'est
encore insuffisant
la majorité des analyses sont réalisées
par pcr une méthode standard éprouvé et
fiable
l'ennui c'est le temps qui s'écoule
entre le prélèvement et la communication
des résultats se compte en jours
l'automne dernier le gouvernement
canadien a donc annoncé l'achat de
différents tests rapides des millions
test capable de fournir des résultats
en une quinzaine de minutes ou plus mais
avant de déployer les responsables de la
santé publique veulent s'assurer que les
performances annoncées par les
fabricants soient validées sur le
terrain mais parce que tu as de masque
on a comme donné ceux des données de la
littérature dans certaines populations
de patients ou certains auteurs ont fait
des études de validation des fois des
petits volumes de passer à des petit
nombre de patients
l'objectif des projets pilotes et de
valider la performance de ces vitesses
deux tests rapides dans la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean
au lac saint jean on a entamé en
décembre un processus de validation sur
deux tests rapides les plus courants
pour l'instant le haiti now et le pain
bio tous deux la compagnie abbott
s'ils ont en commun de pouvoir livrer
des résultats en quelques minutes ils
sont par ailleurs très différent des
tests rapides qui détecte les antigènes
il y en a donc des tec les acides
nucléiques donc les tests rapides noront
ne sont pas tous les mêmes à l'aide de
ce petit appareil le haiti now cible des
fragments de matériel génétique du virus
qu'il amplifie le pain bio lui est un
test antigénique proche d'un test de
grossesse
il cible une protéine du virus comme la
quantité de virus dans notre corps varie
entre le début et la fin de l'infection
on doit cerner à quel moment les tests
rapides sont les plus performants
durant ces tests de validation menées un
peu partout au québec
on mesure la performance des tests
rapides en la comparant aux résultats
obtenus avec la méthode du standard en
laboratoire donc pour la même patient va
effectuer deux prélèvements on va tester
en parallèle le test rapide qu'on veut
valider notre test de référence pour
s'assurer que les résultats concordent
j'ai vraiment pour connaître la santé la
spécificité du ps à ce qu'on a des faux
positifs des fonds négatif alors il faut
vraiment donc étudier tous les pilotes
mac soient négatifs ou positifs
il faut les comparer
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on a fait à québec et à
lévis entre autres où des médecins en
santé publique et des infectiologues ont
élaboré un test de validation pour le
holding
à partir d'échantillons prélevés dans
les narines et dans la gorge chez plus
de 1600 personnes qui présentaient des
symptômes de lakovic 19
depuis loin de sept jours et ce qu'ils
ont observé les a agréablement surpris
on obtient une fiabilité qui aussi en 98
et 99 % pour le test rapide
aïe dinars et qui est tout à fait
comparable à celle obtenue avec le test
faire en laboratoire
c'est bien mais ces résultats ne
concernent qu'un test le à dinard pour
une classe d'individus
il est symptomatique de moins de sept
jours pour le test antigénique pain bio
qui cible une protéine du virus
il faudra attendre une autre série de
tests de validation
les tests de détection rapide entre
chimiques sont moins sensibles que les
tests détectent les acides nucléiques
par ce qui épate des tables
d'amplification du matériel qu'on cible
pour ce test sur la quantité de virus
présent doit être plus grande pour être
en mesure de détecter d'obtenir un
résultat positif avec un test de
détection rapide antigénique tests
rapides antigénique testera pitt décès
du clic
le défi c'est de déterminer la meilleure
utilisation de chacun de ces tests dans
la stratégie globale de dépistage dans
laquelle les tests standards vont
continuer de jouer un rôle important
mais on veut les utiliser avec leurs
forces
alors leurs forces et un test rapide 15
minutes qu'on peut aussi utiliser en
dehors du laboratoire dans les endroits
où le test de l'abattoir standard n'est
pas disponible
on veut aussi les utiliser pour des
populations de patientes marginalisés
comme par exemple des itinérants alors
on irait les rencontrer avec nos
hôtesses et les tester sur place
on peut imaginer que les tests rapides
vont de plus en plus trouver leur place
dans les aéroports par exemple pour
dépister des cas qui n'auraient pas été
détectés autrement les tests rapides
pourraient aussi se répandre en milieu
de travail où des contrôles fréquents
pourraient permettre de prévenir des
éclosions dire effectivement des études
de modélisation qui tendent à démontrer
que si on utilise un test un peu moins
bon qu'un test de laboratoire qui était
plus lent mais qu'en contrepartie on
teste les gens beaucoup plus fréquemment
il pourrait y avoir un gain en termes de
santé publique pour pour lutter contre
la pandémie
plus on en mesure de mettre en place des
mesures de prévention c'est à dire
isoler le patient tester les contacts
qu'ils ont eus rapidement donc c'est
pour nous ça va être un outil utile pour
la gestion des éclosions et de déco
positif c'est clair tests rapides doute
est standard on doit se rappeler qu'un
résultat négatif ne fait pas de nous une
personne immunisés rien n'empêche le
virus de nous attaquer plus tard si
notre garde et baisser
[Musique]